Trudeau,
our prime minister's
great example of that.
So back I think it was in
2015 he announced that half
of his cabinet was going
to be women because it was 2015 or some
like muddle headed virtue signaling,
signaling excuse for not thinking.
I think only 20% or 25% of
the elected mps were female.
So the proper balance on
average would it be 25% female,
75% male.
What he should've done
was figured out who,
what qualities would make for
a competent cabinet minister,
because it's actually quite important
to have competent cabinet ministers and
then selected from among his people
for nothing other than competence,
but he could virtue signal and then
he set up the most important board,
let's say,
of the entire comp country
on a quasi random basis.
Jesus,
how pathetic.
He should've been pilloried
by Canadians for that.
But we're so clued out and and also
in this situation that you described,
it's like if I say,
well,
50% of Trudeau's cabinet
shouldn't have been women.
It's like,
oh,
you're a misogynist.
It's like,
no,
only 25% of the elected
officials were women.
Now you might say,
well,
it would be better if
50% of the were elected.
It's like,
maybe it would be better,
but it didn't happen.
So you can't,
you can't fix it at the top end.
It was appalling.
So it's a hard argument to make,
you know,
because you need to know that there's
more difference within groups then between
them in order to be able to come
up with a credible argument,
you know?
And then so yeah.